even when I don't think about it it's
their vital for me and all life on earth
I could not imagine myself without it
air is constantly moving crossing a vast
area of land and ocean and so are the
many substances floating in the
atmosphere the air contains various
chemical components some of these are
pollutants and we're concentrated in the
air they represent a threat to the
environment and human health most of the
harmful air pollution comes from human
activity harmful substances in the air
enter our respiratory system when we
inhale irritating the nose throat and
lungs this in turn can cause
inflammations resulting in breathing
problems some elements of pollution are
so small that they not only penetrate
deep into the lungs they also pass into
the bloodstream just like oxygen does
this can affect our central nervous
system causing headaches and anxiety
problems breathing polluted air can also
damage our blood cells liver spleen and
our reproductive system long-term
exposure to these pollutants can even
lead to cardiovascular diseases and
cancers every day in Europe human lives
are being cut short by air pollution
many more lives are diminished in other
ways as the effects of chronic
respiratory disease make life miserable
for millions to these direct health
effects we must add the damage inflicted
on our environment and the ecosystems we
rely on for food and water when there
are pollutants in the air we cannot
avoid breathing them indoors or outdoors
in the city or in the countryside so we
need to work together to reduce air
pollution as much as possible because we
all need clean air
you